hi I'm Patti Kim Ireland it's an
exciting mix of the old and the new here
you'll find the quiet of the countryside
and the exuberance of the city but
Ireland is still well stocked with those
glorious castles and windswept
landscapes it really is a jewel of a
destination deserving of its nickname
the Emerald Isle historically Ireland
was divided into the four provinces of
Leinster Munster hunna and Ulster today
most of Ulster is now Northern Ireland
part of the United Kingdom the Republic
of Ireland covers 5/6 of the island its
capital is Dublin
in Dublin start along the river looking
for tours of Dublin's architecture
you
visit trinity college and explorer
Ireland's oldest university its vast
libraries
but for a real brush with history
traveled to the boying Valley in County
Meath and see new great
this massive tube is similar in purpose
to the Pyramids of Giza though it was
built over 5,000 years ago where the
pyramids were even a twinkle in a
Pharaoh's eye
Ireland stone-age inhabitants built it
to house their honor dead and perhaps
for something more
at sunrise on the winter solstice the
shortest day of the year
a beam of light enters the central
chamber what significance this had for
the builders is still a matter of debate
enter the tomb and decide for yourself
the experience is illuminated
a plethora of castles churches and
towers it's not a Cerys became important
centers of learning during the Dark Ages
and its fortresses were strategic
battlegrounds against the islands
frequent invaders the rock of cashel
near Tipperary served both the secular
and religious function according to
legend this Fortress of the Munster
Kings was visited by Saint Patrick
himself and eventually became an
important medieval cathedral
if your tastes cater more towards
scenery than history
you're in luck opportunities abound near
Galway The Cliffs of mohair rise more
than 650 feet from the scene
providing dramatic views of the coast
also nearby are the surreal landscapes
of The Burren
with it's cracked limestone and brooding
ruins when it's time for more leisurely
pace you can travel along the river
shannon ride horses in the khan mara
or stroll through quaint towns in lush
countryside colored in Ireland's forty
shades of green
you